[Música]
les tenemos una noticia muy importante
y es que mañana
nos morimos todos
o no quién sabe no sabemos y es que
sobrevivir a nuestra propia muerte pues
parte como de un anhelo parte de del
miedo también
y podemos pretender que somos humildes y
que asumimos que somos una pequeñita
parte del universo pero precisamente por
eso pues no podemos esperar a que algo o
alguien venga a salvarnos la
infraestructura que soporta nuestra
existencia es este cuerpo esta mente
y pues no sé tal vez lo único que podría
en todo caso sobrevivir son las ideas es
decir la eternidad a través de la
creación
una de las muchas fantasías que tenemos
para después de la muerte es la de que
hemos vivido muchas vidas rodeados
probablemente de las mismas almas en
diferentes cuerpos y en diferentes roles
porque tal vez el secreto sea que no
necesitamos mucho para ser crisis aquí
estamos aquí y aquí podemos tener muchas
vidas
no les pasa cuando ven fotos viejas que
parece que están asomados a la vida de
alguien más ay me cuesta mucho trabajo
creer que era yo el de fotos de hace 20
años 10 años un año la verdad me siento
muy distinto a que el sujeto
yo un día puedo por ejemplo ser
motociclista o tatuar o pertenecer a una
fraternidad antigua pero lo que sí les
puedo garantizar es que si les preparo
unos chiles en nogada o si me pongo a
mezclar una canción soy básicamente la
misma persona porque hay procesos que
aunque son diferentes pueden ser muy
parecidos
una banda a fin de cuentas es como un
microcosmos en nuestro caso somos cuatro
piezas que hasta que no en bonn aaron no
existieron la idea de grant schubert la
idea de este proyecto la tenemos desde
hace ya muchísimos años pero pues en
aquel momento a él hoy no lo conocíamos
sophie vivía en zacatecas tenía 14 años
no fue hasta que nos juntamos que gran
sur no nació y ya como un concepto
definido ya éramos las personas y las
piezas que se requerían
saben que para mí una banda es una tribu
un rompecabezas de piezas imperfectas
pero únicas que nos vamos reinventando y
adaptando para darle vida a las ideas al
ser estas diferentes nos expresamos de
manera diferente por ejemplo yo me
expreso a través de mi batería que es mi
corazón
y si yo soy el corazón
cha
tú eres la mente
[Música]
y tu viña aquí la locura y me encantaría
invitarlos a dar un paseo por mi cabeza
para que vieran todo lo que siento y que
fluye también pero que por alguna razón
se queda atrapado en el trayecto a mi
boca porque de algo si estoy muy segura
si yo lograra darme entender cómo lo
hago con la música definitivamente no
hay música y es que el canto nace del
llanto y el llanto del dolor y de la
alegría
sophie tú serás nuestra alma
[Música]
y
cómo
me decían
si la adicción
comenzar del río bravo terminar la
oración
[Música]
de valiente
llena de amor
no
compensa todo
en mi caso
con el salmón
el corazón
ah
[Música]
y las canciones
estar acompañándonos
y la de la tierra
y termina de desilusión
[Música]
sí
de bala
miras
comienza a ver lo mismo
a mí
con el sabor
y
[Música]
el día
termina de acordar
[Aplausos]
o
[Música]
[Aplausos]